it's time now Fourth Watch Mr GTA hey on
this Monday what's going on good to see
you happy Monday uh Gail congratulations
thanks very exciting King Charles yeah I
like the way it flows uh what else are
we talking about this morning we're
gonna remember Len Goodman a long time
judge on Dancing With the Stars Goodman
died over the weekend in England at the
age of 78 of bone cancer he was head
judge on the series for more than 15
years until he retired in November
before that Goodman was a popular judge
on the BBC version of the show called
Strictly Come Dancing on Dancing With
the Stars the other judges would let the
competitors down softly with their
comments Goodman was known for his
no-nonsense critiques listen
[Applause]
such a joyful thing to watch
feet
it was consistent it was terrible from
start to finish I'm in a very good mood
and I want to be nice if I can be nice
I've been nice once I can only please
one person a week and uh you've missed
it and don't hold your breath for next
week either
wow I know it was very biting uh Dancing
with the Stars judge Bruno tweeted
heartbroken there will never be anyone
like you you will always be my perfect
ten unless anybody think that he was
just a judge he won the British dancing
championship he was a teenager when he
was a young man when he was 19. so he
knew what he was talking about he wasn't
just a good television personality he
always seems so classy too even when
he's saying you're the worst it just
sounded good I know I know you're
terrible yes I agree with you I'm
terrible
time to ever want to watch sorry DJ's
got the head Bob going Steph starts
fighting that list
[Music]
but I turned around and I see Nate he's
just he's like Nate was like I don't
know if I was that intensive but
it works with for me Tony I stick with
it there you go uh all right let's begin
with these stunning allegations about
Britain's royal family just days before
King Charles's coronation in court
documents filed yesterday Prince Harry
claims his brother Prince William
quietly received a large Financial
settlement in a 2020 phone hacking case
against British newspapers Harry is
suing Rupert Murdoch's newspaper group
and alleges the Royals had a secret
agreement that's a quote with the press
to settle Williams case and avoid
embarrassing coverage boy MTS reports
from London
Prince Harry's claim his brother Prince
William had a case against Rupert
Murdoch's newspaper group that was
settled for a large sum is one of a
series of explosive Revelations made in
his witness statement
but the court filings have raised
questions about other possible secret
deals between the Royals I'm sorry and
Britain's tabloid press says former son
tabloid newspaper editor Kelvin McKenzie
there would definitely be on Harry's
side a sense that there was a cozy
cartel between uh the popular papers and
the royal family so he wants to blow
this up he gets back in his own family
he he bashes the tabloids over the head
he gives Murdoch a kick in the pants
there is nothing not to like as far as
Harry's concern
the palace is not commenting on the case
in which Prince Harry alleges since the
mid-2000s he's been the victim of phone
hacking and other illegal behavior that
generated headlines which have destroyed
some of his personal relationships
accusing reporters who worked for Rupert
Murdoch's tabloid newspapers of
illegally accessing his voicemails to
obtain private information about him
over the past decade Murdoch owned
businesses have settled several similar
phone hacking claims for hundreds of
millions of dollars in Damages it's
pretty clear that they are going to do
everything they can not to go to court
no matter what Prince Harry wants Rupert
Murdoch never goes into the witness box
and he'll do everything everything to
stop either him or his other Executives
in London from being cross-questioned
it's a very very big game that's going
on in London right now precipious
morning samithia is tired in London
I thought what was even more interesting
is Harry revealed that uh his
grandmother Queen Elizabeth II was aware
of this settlement of this settlement
yes all right before we go I want to
point out something that you did on
Monday Vlad hosted the 2023 Gala for
figure skating in Harlem the non-profit
organization has used figure skating to
help girls from underserved communities
grow physically emotionally and
academically for more than two decades
some of the U.S figure skating's biggest
stars were at the gala including Scott
Hamilton Nathan Chen Maya and Alex
ibutani so Vlad uh who did you honor so
this is an incredible organization uh we
took time to honor the great great
Michael Kors uh the legendary right of
course designer um Paramount executive
Crystal Barnes I don't know if you had a
chance to meet Crystal Barnes but she
was also honored and photographer Flo
and Gala you will remember that I
interviewed yes
about her stunning photography there is
Flo we did a story on her she came to
prominent events photographing black
lives matter protest but then is now
also cardi B's like personal
photographer and last year became the
first black female photographer to
photograph stars and celebrities on the
red carpet at the Met Gala which was a
huge thing she's under she's on the
Forbes under 30 list this year she's
going to go back to the Met Gala this
year to be on the red carpet I know
she's an incredible incredible Talent
glad you did a great job it's a
wonderful honor do they know you can't
skate at all next question Tony they
know very well uh Sharon Cohen this is
uh Tony and I love you okay you picked
the one time that I fell uh to show mine
yeah it's a one-time Vlad but let me
just tell everybody check out figure
skating in Harlem it is a wonderful
organization run by Sharon Cohen it does
mean a lot to you to stay up late on a
school night yeah the new baby at home
that's exactly right those mean a lot to
you appreciate it I've never went to
watch with the old school Mr vlad's duty
all right it's my thing Tony decopo
Isley Brothers in the house uh all right
let me get right into this this morning
there are some new developments in Fox
news's split with Tucker Carlson the
former host made his first public
comment last night he posted this
two-minute video to Twitter where he did
not mention his exit from Fox directly
or even the reason for his departure it
was a message that seemed to be directed
at his Fox faithful he criticized what
he called a lack of honest political
debate in American Media and ended the
video by saying see you soon meanwhile
there may be some new insight into why
Fox parted ways with Carlson the New
York Times And The Wall Street Journal
reported that private messages sent by
Carlson show him making highly offensive
and crude remarks including one about a
senior Fox News executive the report
says those redacted messages were part
of legal filings in the lawsuit that fox
settled with Dominion voting systems
something tells me we have not heard the
last from Tucker Carlson well he said
see you soon for a reason yeah right
we'll see well I wonder if he's going to
sit for an interview I mean the guys
worked at MSNBC CNN and fox Trifecta
journey I don't know where he is today
all right let's talk about the red
carpet action last night at the time 100
Gala right here in New York City
celebrating the world's most influential
people check out all the stars who
showed up including yes the events host
Jennifer Coolidge Drew Barrymore was
there she looks fabulous and Angela
Bassett John Baptiste right uh queen of
wakanda Angela Bassett in the house and
the queen of my adolescent heart I'm so
excited Judy Bloom folks uh who I've
grown up watching my whole life Katie
Quan They just want an Oscar uh watching
I've read
the queen of our hearts you wasn't
playing huh in the house
oh it was so nice number one people were
so psyched to see Judy Bloom all right
Caleb yes starring Sally Jay yes are you
there God it's me Margaret then again
maybe I won't deeney blubber I mean I
know every I know every boy in the room
there's always somebody you want to see
you didn't know and you just want to
meet it's always a great night
we're gonna start this morning by
looking back at the legacy of long time
talk show host Jerry Springer a family
spokesperson said he died peacefully in
the Chicago area home yesterday after a
battle with cancer of course we all know
him as the host of The Jerry Springer
Show he oh man remember this like yes
I'm just like you pause it even when I'm
reading this I paused and just gotta
watch right that's what made it so
watchable he jokingly referred to
himself as a ring master of
civilizations end it's talk show which
ended in 2018 after a nearly three
decade run was a ratings Powerhouse and
a cultural phenomenon at one point
Springer had more viewers than Oprah he
was getting well I know 12 million
viewers for his show uh very little gets
12 million of viewers now maybe 60
Minutes what many people may not know is
that before his talk show Springer was a
lawyer he was the mayor of Cincinnati
and he did what we did he was a local
news anchor uh but the Jerry Springer
Show obviously made him a household name
and he was very honest about what the
show represented
I I just think it's so outrageous so
crazy
um that it's different than other things
that are on television
um you know I think some days frankly
it's even stupid
you know at least he was in on the joke
people that knew him said he was always
in on the joke yes he was transparently
after the ratings as well when he first
had his show it was an issue orientated
news and policy that's right and it
didn't rate Cincinnati Inquirer called
it oppressively self-important right it
did not rate and so he pivoted he
pivoted to man who marries a horse adult
baby but let me just say one thing I
know that a lot of people said oh it was
appealing to the lowest common
denominator but I argue that as he often
did that it was kind of a democratic
platform because there were people that
you might not have met in your real life
that for the first time had a voice it
may have been allowed an obnoxious voice
no I think it appealed to the lowest
you're real it was also a reflection of
certain pockets of America yes so let's
just that's true I think those are very
small Pockets yeah very small Pockets
within all the chaos within all the
chaos after the show he would say take
care of yourself and each other I love
that which is always he's never opined
he would just be he was the ring Master
but that was rich that line coming after
what we just saw where they're beating
the crap out of here we're gonna miss
you Jerry I had a chance to meet him at
the 2016 Democratic Convention yeah it
was very cool there we are together
and sat for an interview he was a really
he was a gentleman yeah
all right jarika just did a wonderful
story on Brittany Greiner but we want to
share one more thing that she said
Brittany in her first news conference
it's being released from a Russian
prison in December Greiner criticized
State officials who are trying to stop
transgender athletes from playing sports
listen to this
everyone deserves the right to play
everyone deserves the right to to come
here sit in these seats and feel safe
and not feel
um like there's a threat or they can't
be who they are definitely will be
speaking up against
those that legislation and those laws
that are trying to be passed for sure
well she's using her platform to help
others and I always think that's a good
thing 17 states have outlawed gender
affirming care for minors and 16 others
are considering doing the same
Friday uh a seventh grader in Michigan
is earning praise for his heroic actions
on a school bus this week so you can see
the bus driver here begin to lose
Consciousness in this video right 13
year old Dylan Reeves he is 13 years old
he Springs into action he hits the
brakes he steers the bus away from
traffic safely bringing it to a full
stop and then he screams for someone to
call 9-1-1 First Responders were there
within minutes and the bus driver was
taken to the hospital Dylan's parents
spoke to reporters yesterday
I can't even
impress how much
it's a word and proudness you know like
I'm extremely proud of him it does this
shouldn't it's kind of like why us you
know but it's a it's an honor I mean we
got a little hero
yeah uh the school superintendent says
Dylan will be recognized for his bravery
and local leaders plan to honor him as
well I like that his dad said when he
first got the call I thought Dylan was
in trouble that'd be my parents like
what do you do now oh he's a hero oh my
god oh yeah you saved somebody you know
what you never know guys what you're
going to do in that situation so for him
at 13. a lot about who he is it does
well job Mom and Dad what Mom and Dad I
was going to say good job I'm talking
about is the Poise right yeah I mean hit
the brakes steer it out of traffic call
9-1-1 young hero right there that's
right